hello everyone and welcome to yet
another MPI for python tutorial video
for supercomputing parallel programming
in high-performance computing in the
last video I showed you guys how you
could do scatter and now I want to show
you guys how to do gather and now that I
think about it I actually want to use
the same code that we used before
so because first we'll just scatter it
to everybody and then we'll gather it
right back up so let me go ahead and
open up an example here so take the same
code that you had from the previous
video and just copy and paste it no need
to rewrite that code again so when we
get to this point we have you know this
line that it tells us you know the data
that we have and don't forget to get rid
of that plus five if you still have it
and now what we're going to want to do
is come down here and now we're going to
use gather so what we can do now is do
new data equals comm gather data root
and zero so we're going to send it to
route zero earth to node zero and then
we're say at the end of here if rank
equals zero prin master collected new
data okay
so again we're calling this new data now
but obviously referencing data here to
reference this data here so first make
sure you knock over your microphone with
your keyboard and then text let's go
ahead and save this and let's move this
to our super computer and minimize this
up arrow SCT ten
okay so we scattered all the data here's
the data and then we gathered it right
back up and just to get booked okay
just to give a more concrete example I
suppose of this what's let's do this
let's modify the data so each rank got
that data but now what we want to do is
data plus equals one so we're going to
modify this data in some way so in our
supercomputer generally you're not going
to send a message just to send it back
you're gonna send a message it's gonna
do some stuff and then it's going to
send back some stuff okay so we'll save
that and let's move that over now and
run it okay so sure enough we got the
data in the you know correct form here
and then we added one after we spit it
out right so this matches this and then
we added one to the data and sent it
back and the master collected this so
sure enough we can see that we receive
the data modify the data sent it back
and we got it back to the master node
successfully so at this point honestly
you pretty much have all of the
necessary tools or most of the necessary
tools to do supercomputing really the
sending and receiving messages was
pretty much all youyou really needed to
do supercomputing so this stuff is
actually pretty neat I do like scatter
gather and brought especially broadcast
is useful depending on what you're doing
but it's pretty nice to have these kinds
of things built in for you like MPI for
pi is actually a lot more powerful than
I thought it was going to be out of the
box that it does all this
message-passing stuff for you and it
does it really well the next two
commands that you can do are reduce and
scan and reduces
a lot like gather and then scan is I
don't know in a world of its own so I'm
not really sure I'm trying to think of a
good good example of why you would use
them you always see them being used with
well at least like scan you're gonna see
scan being used with these Mandelbrot
fractal nets or whatever but anyway
maybe we'll get into some of those in
some future videos but anyways hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support in the subscriptions and until
next time